okay um thank you everyone from for
joining my webinar today my name is nick
asbrock
i'm a product manager for the stem cell
and the 3d cell culture products
at millipore sigma
which is the life science business of
merck kgaa
dharmasat germany in north america
so today i'm going to talk about a new
product that was recently launched
called truegel 3d
hts hydrogel plates
this is a new product that will enable
high throughput drug screening in 3d
cell cultures
so an overview of 3d cell culture
so this is a recently
discovered way to culture cells
it kind of bridges the gap between
traditional two-dimensional cell culture
models
and in vivo animal models
so a lot of the advantages of
3d cell culture is that um you get
really this native morphology
that you see in in vivo animal models
but you get the added advantage of being
more high throughput ready
which is what 2d cell cultures are so
a lot of people are interested in using
these 3d cell culture models
for a lot of drug discovery
or just
basic biological assays
in general
so in terms of methods to grow cells in
3d
there are many different ways to grow
cells in 3d
they're listed here
i'll go through each one of them briefly
so
the first one is hydrogel scaffolds
these are
either natural or synthetic options
that will encapsulate cells and once
they're encapsulated the cells will then
grow in 3d
there's also um structural scaffolds so
the these are usually non-biological
these are more like um
like structural or rigid scaffolds where
the cells
will be
grown on the scaffolds and then they
they migrate throughout the scaffolds
itself
you can grow cells as cell aggregates as
well so these are freely floating
aggregates of cells that float around in
the media
you can also grow these in bioreactors
or organs on a chips
today i'm going to talk about the true
gel 3d
hydrogel which is kind of the first
method listed here with the star
so and brief overview of what hydrogels
are they are a form
of a biological scaffold so these are
water swollen polymers
that can be derived from ecm proteins or
synthetic
chemicals
and as you can see on the image on the
left
the cells can be encapsulated within the
hydrogel itself to form this
3d environment
and what you see when you grow cells
in this 3d environment is that the cells
have a more in vivo like cellular
response
and the analogy that i always think of
when i think of hydrogels is like jello
it's kind of like jello for cells that's
kind of what it's like
okay so when it comes to high throughput
screening
using 3d models
there are some limitations on using
current
products or methods
to culture cells in 3d using hydrogels
so they're listed here
for each model that you're trying to
create
usually the hydrogel has to be optimized
for all the different applications
so that would require different
you know
hydrogel stiffnesses hydrogel growth
factors or ecm proteins there's a lot of
upfront work
that needs to be
performed in order to have the right
environment for the cells of your choice
some of the materials are very
temperature sensitive
so
um
it's not the easiest to use some of
these materials
some of the materials are not
transparent they're kind of opaque
so it can be difficult to do some
endpoint assays
one once you have the cells in the
hydrogels itself because it's difficult
to image
um it's also difficult to establish coal
cultures so once you have your cells
embedded in
the current hydrogels it's really hard
to add additional cells at a
future time point
to the hydrogel itself
and kind of the main hydrogels used now
are also animal derived and i know there
is a
[Music]
there is a trend towards more defined
conditions for reproducibility
concerns
okay so this is an overview of the new
product
the truegel 3d hts hydrogel plate
as you can see here it's a 96 well
black walled glass bottom plate
so within each well of the plate there's
actually an hydrogel on the bottom
of the well
and the unique thing about the hydrogel
is that it has this cross-linking
density gradient throughout the well
itself
so on the top of the hydrogel is low
density gradient
and when you go through the hydrogel or
towards the bottom it gets higher and
higher density so there's this gradient
throughout the hydrogel itself
and this allows you to do a couple
different things um there's actually no
hydrogel step required so it's a precast
hydrogel
um if a customer wants to use this it's
really easy to use you just take it out
of the wrapping and
take out the buffer and add cells to it
and over time the cells will infiltrate
the hydrogel because of the density
gradient
it's also fully synthetic
so it's a peg-based hydrogel
so there's no animal components it's
very consistent from lot to lot
and because of the density gradient you
can actually do sequential seeding so
it's really easy to establish coal
cultures over time
it's as easy as just adding cells at
different time points
and i'm going to go through each one of
these
in more detail
in the future slides
so about the hydrogel itself so like i
said before
within each well of the 96 well plate
there's a precast hydrogel in the bottom
of the well
they're
they come deliver hydrated
and ready for cell seeding so
the customer just has to remove the
storage buffer and add cells and media
to the hydrogel it's as easy as that
um it has this cross-linking density
gradient it is a patented technology and
this is the real
advantage of the product we see this
density gradient
um
for those of you who are interested in
the actual chemistry of the hydrogel
this is an overview of
what the hydrogel is made of
so like i said before it is a synthetic
hydrogel it's peg-based
so it's very consistent from lot to lot
it is functionalized self-functionalized
so it has
rgd peptide sequences throughout the
hydrogel and it also has these
degradation sites
so once cells are embedded in the the
matrix they can actually degrade the
hydrogel over time and the cells can
actually move throughout the hydrogel
so it is definitely functionalized for
cells
because it is synthetic it has a very
long shelf life as well and it's very
consistent from lots a lot
um if you are interested in more of the
chemistry behind the hydrogel
and how it was developed there is a
publication here which describes the
overall chemistry of the true gel
hydrogel plates
so like i said before the the product is
really easy to use and then
and in fact the doing the coal culture
is
actually really easy to use as well so
to use it you basically remove the
storage buffer
and then you just add cells and media
to the wells and you incubate overnight
and come in the next day and the cells
will infiltrate the hydrogel and find
kind of it's it's it's a preferred niche
within the hydrogel itself
you can then come in the next day if you
wanted to and then add another cell type
and incubate overnight
and you will then create this coal
culture
after basically two days of waiting
so it's really easy to use
so that was an overview of the plate
itself
i'm now going to go through more the
application data for the product
so we have seven applications
listed here
using the plates and cells today i'm
going to talk about the first four
so the first application is
immuno-oncology
so we wanted to use
the plates
to establish a tumor cell killing assay
using tumor cells and some experimental
compounds
so on the top you can see three
conditions
the first condition is tumor cells plus
the compound in green is the cells that
are dying
the middle
condition
was tumor cells
plus non-activated t cells
the t cells are in red and the third
condition is kind of like the positive
control so this is tumor cells
plus activated t cells so the compound
was thought to activate the t cells to
kill the tumor cells over time
and what you see is in this third
condition you see
actually um increased tumor cell killing
so a higher number of green cells
and we did quantify it and as you can
see when we spike in the compound at a
higher ratio
you get a higher tumor cell killing
response
so the higher green fluorescence which
means more of the tumor cells are dying
so we also did um let's see here
so we also did a kind of dose response
and also different ratios of tumor cells
to
activated t cells
so this is using a human lung
cancer cell line the ebc1
and this just displays that you know
over time you can do this really
powerful culture method within the true
gel plates itself
and you get really high
clarity you can get these really high
resolution images
and you can actually you can see cells
in real time as well so we actually did
this um
[Music]
experiment and we took some videos over
i think two days
and this is what happens so once again
the t cells are in red
the tumor cells are
um
the gray ones and the green ones are the
tumor cells that are dying
so over a two day period you can see
how you should see more green cells pop
up so the red cells are killing the
tumor cells and they're producing this
green
fluorescence which are the dying cells
and this is all within the hydrogel
itself this 3d environment
okay the application 2
was kind of related to application 1. we
wanted to show that the plates can
support just tumor spheroid growth
so we took these human pancreatic cancer
cell lines this mia paca2 cells
and we cultured them over time over two
weeks in um the hydrogel plates
and we stained for cytokeratin 19.
and as you can see the cells really do
form these spheroids within
the hydrogel plate itself
this is just kind of
the z-stacks of the
spheroids so top middle and bottom
you do see these feroids grow throughout
the hydrogel itself
so the cells will embed within the
hydrogel and then over time the skewers
will grow larger
throughout the gel
so the next experiment was taking kind
of the same spheroid
model and we wanted to do it
kind of a drug drug screening
so we took um
our these are different cells so these
are ebc1 cells
so we seeded 5000 cells per well in the
hydrogel plates we then did a drug
screen using this investigational
compound compound a
and we analyzed the
the
toxicity of the cells
to to the drugs so we did a dose
response curve
so what you see here is with increasing
concentration of compound a
you see the spheroids actually get
smaller and smaller because the compound
is becoming toxic to the cell
we also did a screen with two other
compounds
um investigational compounds and you can
see how they have similar effects
on the spheroids
but i mean the ic50s are different but
you do see a higher concentration of
compound becomes toxic to the cells
this is just some images that you can
generate using the spheroid plates so we
took that compound a
and we did the dose response curve so
increasing concentrations of drugs
and this is basically what you see over
time you start seeing more of the cells
dying
so they're kind of like producing these
fragments of cells at these higher
concentrations which are like the dead
cells
and what we actually did we used an
imaging software
to actually count all these little cell
aggregates
so we call it like cell bursting this is
called like a cell burst assay
so the higher number of fragments means
that the compound is becoming toxic to
the cells and you can actually localize
to see where the toxicity is occurring
if you wanted to
and what we did is we did this
[Music]
analysis where we took compound a
at a dose response
varying concentrations of compound a
we quantify the number of bursts
at each concentration and then we also
took the spheroid size
so it's kind of um
it's pretty obvious that with the more
cell bursting which is what the blue
line is at higher concentrations
the spheroid size is going down
so in theory you could
use this assay to
kind of predict the the most appropriate
drug concentration
to
basically
kill
the majority of your tumor without
becoming toxic to other cells
okay um application three
um it's also cancer related
so there is a
a large interest in
kind of mimicking the tumor cell
microenvironment
so what we wanted to do was to do this
coal culture of the tumor spheroids
with
the cancer associated fibroblasts
so what we did we labeled the fibroblast
in rfp so red
and we created these tumors for steroids
this is also
the pancreatic cancer cell line again
and then we co-culture these tumor
spheroids with
the red labeled fibroblasts over time
for up to two weeks
and as you can see within the 3d
hydrogel itself
the fibroblasts actually start wrapping
around the tumor cells
and this is kind of thought to create
that tumor cell micro environment
and once again because of the properties
of the hydrogel
it's you can get these really clear
high resolution images to see what's
going on within the 3d environment
itself
and because it's high throughput 96
wells you can do drug screening if you
wanted to and
analyze different drug responses within
this environment itself
you can also analyze the um
the
the
extracellular matrix
deposits throughout the hydrogel so what
we did here was
we took some fibroblasts which was
labeled as rfp
we grew them for um
i think a couple a couple weeks and then
you can actually analyze what ecm
proteins are
deposited throughout the hydrogel itself
so in b
is
fiber nectin
in green
and c is actually
collagen
c and d are collagen d is we added
ascorbic acid to the conditions to
increase the collagen deposition
so when cells are grown in this 3d
environment within the hydrogel itself
it definitely is producing its own ecm
proteins throughout the gel itself so
really creating this 3d
micro environment
so we also have another video
so what we wanted to do was co-culture
tumor spheroids with the fibroblasts so
kind of like this um conditions up here
to create that tumor cell
microenvironment
and so for this experiment we created
the tumor spheroid
and then once it was to a certain size
we then spiked in
uh cancer-associated fibroblasts
throughout the gel itself to create this
coal culture of tumor spheroids and
fibroblasts so trying to mimic
what's happening in the tumor or the
cancer tissue itself
and as you can see the fibroblasts kind
of surround the tumor
and they they kind of like wrap around
the tumor spheroid itself
itself and they create like this this 3d
micro environment surrounding the
spheroid
let me play it again
and once again because of the optical
properties of the gel you get these
beautiful images you can do live cell
imaging
with the coal cultures as well
so this is definitely crosstalk between
the fibroblasts and the tumor steroids
which is what's happening in in vivo
um application 4
is angiogenesis
so
the plates are definitely
can be used for angiogenesis assays
so what we did here was we used um gfp
labeled hubec cells
and what we did it was an experiment
where we spiked in different growth
factors to see if it could inhibit
or
induce angiogenesis
so spiking in vegf definitely increases
the tube formation or the sprouting of
the endothelial cells the vegf also
increases
and then neptrin 4 is an inhibitor
of angiogenesis
and we do see an inhibition over the
control
model
we also quantified this it's in the
paper
that i mentioned before i just didn't
present the data here
okay so um like i said before
these plates have been used in a lot of
different applications not only the ones
i um
presented here
they've been used for
numerous stem cell cultures
they've also been used for a lot of
neuroscience applications as well so
creating
these co-cultures of
astrocytes and neurons and ips derived
neurons
it's also been used for adminitox
applications
so we've cultured liver cells and
different
stellite cells and we've done coal
cultures of liver cells and steroid
stellate cells within the hydrogels
itself
and it works really great
if you're interested in any of this data
or other information about the product
we do have a landing page on sigma
here is
the the url on the top
and um
yeah a lot of this data is on this tech
article
it's a it's a really good reference if
you're interested in the product to
learn more about the features and
benefits and also the chemistry behind
the plates and how to create some of
these more complex 3d cell culture
models that i presented today
i think now
that is my last slide so i think we're
on to the questions section